the indigenous peoples of the world
earth in a way kind of endangered today
for lack of a better term it's not so
much that people are literally dying off
it's that the cultures are being lost
we're actually going through a period of
cultural mass extinction at the moment
no we don't know exactly the rate at
which this is happening linguists tell
us that of the 6,000 languages spoken
around the world today by various people
by the end of the century between half
and 90% will no longer be spoken
they'll be extinct and how this
typically occurs again is not that the
people themselves go extinct but they
you know they leave behind their ancient
villages they move to perhaps a growing
mega city Sao Paulo or or Chennai or
whatever it might be and when they do
they enter the dominant culture and
their kids start to speak the dominant
language and they lose touch with the
old ways and pretty soon that language
in that culture have died they've ceased
to exist that people are still there
their DNA is still there it's entered
the melting pot you know the molecules
are still floating around but they've
lost that geographic context so in
effect the the trail the genetic trail
that our ancestors left in the DNA of
indigenous peoples around the world is
being subsumed into this global
monoculture as this happens and so we
actually have kind of a closing window
of opportunity in which to do this work
you know we're trying to get this
genetic snapshot of what our ancestors
bequeathed to us these genetic trails
that lead all over the world before
they're all mixed and mashed together
you know this is probably a good thing
socially everybody's coming back
together and mixing up and it's going to
be harder and harder to tell one group
from another but it makes our lives very
very difficult as population geneticists
because we can't trace these distinct
migratory routes they're in the process
of in laws